did it make you think at all about like
yourself as a dad one day and maybe kind
of like the pitfalls and dangers of fame
very very much I mean not even fame just
in terms of just being a father it did
I'm not a dad and one day perhaps it
will be nice and it but it made me
scared
it made me scared they're so delicate
and the world is such a terrifying place
and it did put the fear of God into me
and I even feel that way I feel
protective about will as well you know
and we only work together for it for 10
weeks well he looks like you like a pro
now I know I know but he's off but he's
also like the nicest child in the world
the coolest kid as well like a very very
funny young man is just you can't help
but just worry but he's got a great
family so he'll be fine
yeah that's good what do you think is
this fair to say that the real-life
Christopher Robin was maybe when her
first like a viral stars we have a lot
of young viral stars now his parents put
them up yeah and then YouTube and
whatnot he was sir I mean he was famous
in a way that very few children in the
world ever had been famous before that
and very quickly as well those books
went huge very very fast and he really
suffered he really suffered because of
it yeah yeah for sure
do you do you think that given his like
and before he passed away he kind of
made peace you know yes with with all do
you think like what he kind of went
through was worth it for all these
people to have enjoyed your stories
that's a really interesting question I
don't know I can't speak for somebody
who went through that um especially as a
child that's such a difficult thing I
would say that the world as a whole is
so much better for the beauty that Alan
Milne gave to them in the form of
Christopher Robin and Winnie the Pooh it
really helped a lot of people you know
it's really a safe place for people to
go the fact that it damaged the real
life Christopher Robin is such a strange
quirk of fate and so sad and yes I don't
know in the world's a better place but
his life was not for a while that's very
interesting well certainly like millions
of people have been touched by it like
the characters many of the people
there's a character for everyone who do
you relate to the most you like a poo a
piglet a Tigger Hootie's they keep going
you're yeah yeah are for sure man I head
down and just like I'm not sure what I
want to do today I can
that I think we all of you or moments
that I think I probably exist in that
world how do you how do you get like who
like proverbially drags you out of your
do you got you got you got to know you
got to know a few Winnie the Pooh's I
guess you got to surround yourself with
piglets and waiting the booze I guess
that's the only way to get are worse for
a second well I mean as much as I miss
but you can his general Hux gonna lead
gonna lead us out of kylo Ren this time
like what can we see obviously I'm not
gonna tell you that I I don't I don't
know I don't know here's the truth about
being in Star Wars you don't know how
much you're gonna be in Star Wars or
what you're dooming him steroids until
you see the movie because it's not like
winter movies where when you do ADR you
could see the whole film and you get to
see it before it's released Star Wars
the first night I see Star Wars will be
the person that everybody else sees Star
Wars so I'm waiting to find out as much
everybody else and I think I'm just
least excited as everybody else so we'll
wait and see is the answer